halo ist ein instrument und wie sieht es
mit ihm aus hast du kontakt zu ihm
ich sage einmal also nichts mitbekommen
aber so vertrag bei fielmann cool ins
ein instrument lernen ich gerade zu
spielen und wie es aussieht
da sage ich nur 42 bank tv fragt wer ist
der stärkste rapper in deinen augen also
wieso der stärkste oder mit captain der
stärkste also 60 liegestütze schaffe ich
locker mit dem bauch wer der stärkste
ist kann ich dir nicht sagen aber ich
stehe gerne als herausforderer chagaev
goes my name habe zwei fragen an dicht
die erste wäre was hält wohl bushido
beziehungsweise von seiner musik und die
zweite ist das neue lied kamera
herausgekommen ist richter geworden was
eine wahre geschichte ja oder nein
kommendes album wie scharlach das mittel
entsetzlich was mir besorgen bis dahin
viel erfolg also ergo an erster stelle
du sollst dir nicht besorgen sondern
kaufen mein album und bushido ja ich
kenne seine musik nicht ich kann dazu
nichts sagen ich höre die musik nicht
von daher konnte es nur die eine frage
beantworten dennis pohl hat fragt
würdest du sie durchschlagen wenn es
sein muss man sowas denkt ich kann
niemals eva j montana hast du wirklich
haarausfall oder ist das absichtlich mit
der glatze ja ich hab mit 13 40 uhr
auswahl gehabt und habe mich mit 18
jason statham gefühlt und jetzt mache
ich natürlich mit absicht immer schon
weg
alpa gun ich hätte da eine frage und
zwar was hältst du von new orleans block
und das war meine frage
ich verfolge die web szene nicht so und
krieg von den aktuellen newcomer nicht
so viel mit aber ich habe ein paar
sachen gehört ganz so frisch mach dein
ding aber nichts gegen christoph
inschallah 1997 fragt alter bruder du
bist schon 32 jahre wie lange willst du
noch musik machen und wenn es mit der
musik zu ende ist wir hoffen nicht was
danach
ich werde noch musik machen solange ich
noch kann und wenn nicht dann werde ich
hoffentlich ein restaurant eröffnen